-Performing "Still C U"
from her new album "Yessie,"
please welcome Jessie Reyez!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah-yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah,
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Mm ♪
♪ The best advice I ever got
was just to let it go ♪
♪ Family says I smile a lot more
when I'm on my own ♪
♪ But when I finally feel free ♪
♪ You get the urge
to message me ♪
♪ You swear
you never miss a beat ♪
♪ And the song is on repeat ♪
♪ I still see you in my sleep ♪
♪ How come I still see you
when I dream? ♪
♪ I've been running
from the truth ♪
♪ But it don't matter
what I do ♪
♪ It never matters what I do,
I just can't get away from you ♪
-♪ Yeah-yeah ♪
-♪ Can't get away from you ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ When you got a girl,
I got myself an enemy ♪
♪ 'Cause I need all your
attention like a centerpiece ♪
♪ And though we're both trying
to be friends ♪
♪ And though we're
both way past the end ♪
♪ Of everything we could have
been ♪
♪ My broken heart
still lets you in ♪
♪ Still see you when I sleep ♪
♪ How come I still see you
when I dream? ♪
♪ I've been running from the
truth ♪
♪ But it don't matter
what I do ♪
♪ Never matters what I do,
I can't get away ♪
♪ Still see you in my sleep ♪
♪ How come I still see you
when I dream? ♪
♪ I been running from the truth,
but it don't matter what I do ♪
♪ Never matters what I do,
I can't get away ♪
♪ Good thing
I never held my breath ♪
♪ I would've died
an early death ♪
♪ Waiting for you to value me ♪
♪ Waiting for you
to fail my test, yeah ♪
♪ F is for faking love,
F is for forgetting us ♪
♪ F is for feelings that faded ♪
♪ While you...around
and left me ♪
♪ Down, down, down ♪
♪ With every girl
that you found, found, found ♪
♪ I'm like Mary,
going down, down, down ♪
♪ You're like a dog
in a pound, pound, pound ♪
♪ Had me looking
like a clown, clown, clown ♪
♪ Got me out here
crying out loud ♪
♪ Especially
when the sun go down ♪
♪ Hit me when the sun go down ♪
♪ I still see you when I sleep ♪
♪ How come I still see you
when I dream? ♪
♪ I've been running
from the truth ♪
♪ But it don't matter
what I do ♪
♪ Never matters what I do,
I can't get away ♪
♪ Still see you in my sleep ♪
♪ How come I still see you
when I dream? ♪
♪ I been running from the truth,
but it don't matter what I do ♪
♪ No matter what I do ♪
♪ I can't get awa-a-a-y
from yo-o-o-o-o-u ♪
♪ I can't get away
fro-o-o-o-o-m you ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]